Whenever a movie franchise breaks new ground
in Hollywood, or looks like the next big fad,
rival studios rush to make sure they have
at least one similar property on the way.
But overseas, where copyright laws, and blatantly
ripping off entire movies are a grey area,
a carbon copy can still be successful.
And sometimes, an adaptation can reach heights
– or depths – that the original could
never have imagined.
We want to hear your comments about these
so make sure you sound off in the comment
section below!
Here are Screen Rant’s 10 Amazing Movies
You Won’t Believe Were Made.
Turkish Captain America
Sometimes, a movie looking to profit off of
popular superheroes doesn’t care about story
as much as it does the costumes.
In the 1973 Turkish movie “3 Giant Men,”
Captain America joins forces with the famous
Mexican hero Santo – and brings his girlfriend
– to take down the evil Spider-Man taking
over organized crime in the country’s capitol.
Next to nothing from the comics is adapted
to the movie, with Cap murdering a version
of the Spider-Man who can’t really be killed.
Marvel obviously wasn’t happy with the film,
but it released across Turkey anyway.
Brazilian Star Wars
There’s no movie series bigger than Star
Wars, and success means plenty of big screen
parodies and spoofs.
Spaceballs put a funny twist on the series
in the States, but Brazil came up with its
own.
“The Tramps in the War of Planets” put
a trio of Brazilian stooges into a galaxy
far, far away, complete with a golden Darth
Vader and Chewbacca, too.
Unfortunately, there’s a reason most parodies
of Star Wars fall flat, no matter where they’re
made.
Indonesian Terminator
The name of this Indonesian knockoff – Lady
Terminator – says it all, but the Terminator
rip-off made just years after the original
sticks closer to its plot than most dare.
Replace a futuristic robot with a woman possessed
by an angry sea goddess who uses sex to kill
her victims, and you’ve got a clear picture
of why Lady Terminator is still fun to watch.
The filmmakers clearly loved James Cameron’s
Terminator, recreating entire scenes and action
sequences, so it’s hard to judge this rip-off
too harshly.
Especially when the movie is so violent, it
makes Terminator seem like a family-friendly
adventure.
Hong Kong Street Fighter
The official Street Fighter movie isn’t
exactly a successful adaptation, but an unofficial
Chinese version of the game’s story made
its way to theatres a year before.
Unofficial means that characters like Ken,
Chun-Li and E. Honda were replaced with knockoffs
Kent, Chun May and Toyota.
If that doesn’t make it clear that “Future
Cops” was a comedy, its story should: the
hero cops travel back in time from the year
2043 to the distant past of 1993 to keep the
movie’s villain from killing a single government
official.
To be fair, the official movie didn’t make
much more sense.
Japanese Spider-Man
Marvel’s resident web-slinger may be famous
around the world, but that’s probably not
due to this Japanese movie.
Ditching the Peter Parker story completely,
the series re-cast Spider-Man as a motorcycle
racer who stumbles onto a crashed spaceship,
and is injected with blood by the last survivor
of the Planet Spider.
The superhero uses a magic bracelet to shoot
webs and even command his own battle robot,
the Leopardon.
It’s a silly idea, but when the series ended,
the production company used the giant robot
idea in the Super Sentai franchise – the
TV show that would eventually be adapted into
the Power Rangers.
Turkish Batman
You’d have to be crazy to make a Batman
movie without actually reading a Batman comic,
right?
For the Turkish rip-off, the Adam West TV
show was the real basis, following two men
dressed as Batman and Robin – barely – who
punch, kick, and occasionally shoot criminals
dead.
When the Dark Knight isn’t randomly bedding
women.
Even so, if you asked comic book fans, they
might not all agree that Turkey produced the
WORST Batman movie they’ve ever seen…
Indian Superman
The 1988 movie Dariya Dil isn’t too out
of place in Bollywood love stories, and stories
of family drama – apart from one stunning
musical number.
As the movie’s hero tries to woo a young
woman, the two are inexplicably shown in costume
as Superman and Spider-Man, recreating the
flight from Richard Donner’s first Superman
movie.
No explanation for the change is offered,
meaning the superhero costumes and scene make
no actual sense in the larger story.
But when the clip finally made its way online,
the sequence – and the movie – found a
larger audience than the filmmakers could
have ever dreamed.
Turkish Star Trek
If you haven’t noticed already, the laws
against copyright infringement are pretty
loose in Turkey, which meant that in 1973,
popular comedy character Omer the Tourist
made a trip into the realm of Spock, Kirk,
and the rest of the USS Enterprise crew.
The movie recreates an episode from the Original
Star Trek series called “The Man Trap,”
but with a lost Omer replacing the episode’s
salt-hungry alien menace.
It’s a strange choice for a big screen parody,
but the movie managed to beat Star Trek: The
Motion Picture to movie theaters by six years.
Italian Jaws
If a killer Great White Shark can take the
American box office by storm, why not release
a movie with the same plot, but an even bigger
shark, and even more victims?
That was the thinking behind Great White:
The Last Shark, an Italian movie released
six years after Steven Spielberg’s Jaws.
But the rip-off actually hit American theaters,
grossing $18 million before Universal had
it banned for ripping off Jaws.
You can’t call the Italian filmmakers cowardly,
though – in some regions, they actually
advertised the imitation Jaws as a sequel
in the same series.
Indian Nightmare on Elm Street
In the world of ‘80s slasher movies, A Nightmare
on Elm Street managed to stand out by setting
its grisly murders in the dreams of teenagers,
an added twist that made Freddy Krueger an
immortal horror icon.
The Indian rip-off, The Monster, lifted the
entire plot – and the killer’s bladed
glove – but with an even better twist.
Since the movie was made in the Bollywood
image, its version of Freddy Krueger got to
take part in a handful of musical numbers.
So in this case, we’ll leave fans to decide
if the rip-off was actually an improvement
over the original.
So what do you think of our list?
Did we miss any of your favorite foreign language
rip-offs, spoofs, or parodies?
Let us know in our comment section and don't
forget to subscribe to our channel to watch
more videos like this one.